i want to actually go into some of the
the tips that you have
one of the first ones is um regarding
cliches so i'm curious
what is one of the most cliche pieces of
screenwriting advice that's actually
absolutely true and then vice versa
most cliche piece of screenwriting
advice that is false
okay so cliche that is absolutely
writing is rewriting or something
sure
let me think about that for a second uh
one that's true and one that's false so
a true cliche in my opinion
i would say is that you should write
every day um
because if you get in the habit of not
writing then you're going to stay in the
habit of not writing
if you get the habit of writing you're
going to keep writing
if you're in this to be like if you want
to take time off everyone needs
time off you're going to burn yourself
out if you if you write
like and never have fun you know so you
still gotta you still gotta take time
but if you're not writing every day then
you're not getting in the habit of
writing and it's way too
easy to just sit back and go watch
shows instead of writing your own show
and then you don't get stuff done and
that's why it takes
people they've been writing the same
script for the last two years
you know and they're not even close to
done with it yet you know like oh yeah i
got the first act on
really in a in two years um
or they've written just one script and
then never anymore and they're just
shopping on the same script for five
years and have don't have any additional
stuff so button the seat is a must
that i think is absolutely true uh one
that i think is absolutely not true
is um that you
have to have everything format perfect
there are certain things that you do
need to have it needs to look like a
screenplay so if you turn something that
looks like a novel
it's going to get thrown in the trash
there are certain components that it
needs to have it needs to have dialogue
it needs to have
unless it's a silent film it also needs
to have description and it should look
about the same but nobody's gonna
fault you if like you have one too many
lines
in your description uh so like the thing
even in my book i mentioned that you
should try to have four
lines or less in your description
paragraphs nobody's gonna fall at you if
it's five lines they're not gonna be
like oh this one paragraph is fine no no
can't do it
um typos are
one that i would say you absolutely
should fix if you can
but there are plenty of professional
writers who have the occasional typo so
they're not going to throw it in the
garbage the first type of they see
unless the table is on page one then
they're probably going to throw it in
the garbage immediately
um so yeah i would say that the
formatting
can oh and then like bolding or not
bolding your slug lines is another
formatting thing where people are like
oh if you
like nobody like you can't bold your
your slug lines
yes you can you can't underline your
slug lines yes you can
they're not gonna throw it away as long
as the story's good they're gonna
forgive you like minor faux pas or
alterations of the formatting
um so they're not gonna be like oh this
is not written correctly they will do it
if it looks nothing like a script though
i will say that
if it doesn't even look like a
screenplay then they'll throw it away
um but even even things like page length
is is
there's some give you know if it you
know i've heard that if it's not
90 pages 120 pages if it's less than 90
or more than 120 it'll get thrown away
that's not true
if it's 120 to 123 pages i won't have
fun reading it
but i'm not going to throw it in the
garbage you know if a producer
if i think it's good enough story you
know for a producer because i do reading
on the side too as one of my
side gigs and stuff for like producers
and for contests and stuff you know
um yeah okay again i feel like i talked
way too long no no i like that okay so
um those are the two one that's a cliche
that that is true and one that's a
cliche uh
that maybe there's some give on um tip
number one
experts are liars yeah so
a lot of screenwriting books i feel
are there to sell screenwriting books
and one of the first things i say in my
book is that i'm not a guru or an expert
of any kind
you know i here's what i've done here's
what i haven't done i'm not going to lie
to you and say i know the answers
a lot of screenwriting gurus will tell
you like this is the way it needs to be
done that's why i'm writing this book so
that you do it right
there are so many ways in this industry
to to be a writer like i said some
people outline some people don't
um some people follow
different methodologies of storytelling
you know like some people may follow
blake snyder's beat sheet some people
may follow
the the hero's journey they're very
similar things but they're different i
even in the book i talk about like five
or six
different methods of storytelling even
i'm not saying one is better than the
other and that you need to write this
way i'm saying here are the options for
you you know
what are they uh let me just let's let's
if you can pause the tape oh sure sure
yeah
uh let's see 134 is where stories starts
so it's probably around there again i
don't know my
i don't have everything memorized
all right let's see five types of
conflict there's
okay so we got aristotle's version
uh we got the blake lake uh
snyder's save the cat beat sheet heroes
journey
sid fields paradigm uh the five act
structure
the forex structure because usually
you've got three act structure and stuff
well these guys are telling you there
are more
structures you can do than just three
act we got the mini movie method
uh we got max landis's rule of three uh
you know so it's like there's that's
what one two
three four five six seven eight
different versions of storytelling that
i
talk about here there might even be more
later on if i messed up on how i
numbered my tips in here that's
excellent but uh
yeah so which do you prefer when you're
writing
i honestly don't use any of them i just
write a story
like i said i'm outlining like crazy and
then revising my outline until i get a
bulletproof story
so i'm not really going with you know
any of these specific things like we got
the blake snyder you got you know your
opening image
setup stated uh state your theme then
the catalyst the debate
the breaking act two i don't really
think about any of that when i'm doing
act one i'm just starting with
okay how does this how does the world
open
so that we can know who the character
we're gonna follow is and what's gonna
happen in this story
i feel like you the one thing is that by
the end of act one we should know what
the story is gonna be about
but i'm not gonna break it down because
i i believe in blake snare's book he
actually gives you even specific
page page numbers of where the thing
should happen by
i'm like that's way by the numbers like
they're
it takes away too much creativity i feel
if you're gonna be like
that the the the exception i would say
is in television writing
because you've got to go to the
commercials
um if you're on net if you're on like a
broadcasting like nbc or something but
versus streaming um that you need to
have like each act end with some kind of
cliffhanger
to bring the audience back after the
commercial break um
and you need to do we need if you're
gonna
i would say your a story and b story you
should have them in certain spots so
that it flows throughout the thing
but for feature writing i don't know
that any of these are
necessarily need to be in any specific
order or by a certain page count
as long as they're there um because you
know you
look at forrest gump it you can
if you look at forrest gump it's act one
is like five minutes
tops and then the rest of it's an act
two for the most part you know and then
act three is like that
you know whereas whereas some methods
tell you that like act one should be
ending on like between page 25 and 30.
well
forrest gump quelled that didn't it you
know it's act one is
up until he's an adult and then suddenly
he's going off to war and like now we're
already in act two
and we're only like five to ten minutes
into the movie tops you know
right but do you think for a newbie
screenwriter because you know i'm
thinking about like a chef and i
remember i saw the professional a
professional chef another
job i've had by the way oh yeah once oh
nice
okay so you're used to conflict and
being under stress and
i've done everything so so and i asked
the chef do you measure and
the the chef scoffed and said no that's
for amateurs or whatever
and but do you think that after a while
then you don't need to say
sure by this page there's gonna be this
plot point
you know well okay so i feel like it's a
little bit different though because i
will absolutely agree with the chef
thing because if i'm cooking something
for the very first time as a recipe i've
never used before i'm gonna
follow the recipe to the thing but then
once i know what it's supposed to look
like and tastes like
i can just start eyeballing it you know
my mom has not used her measuring cups
since
probably the day i was born um she just
kind of like
okay the recipe calls for a cup that's
about a cup there we go boom
you know um you just kind of go by taste
at that point but um
and i would say doing by taste is is a
good
phrase to use for for the script and
stuff is that
these are all the guidelines but it you
know if you
if you change your mac and cheese recipe
a little bit it's
still a damn good mac and cheese just
not the same mac and cheese that this
person made
and so it's you know you're do it you
know so it's same thing with the scripts
like these are your outlines of
of how of the general story right so
like the hero's journey you know you've
got like your epic adventure here
here's how it would look but if you
tweak some stuff along the way
tell a different story it's not better
or worse than what he's got it's a
different story you know
um and it might be better if the
ingredients you use
fit the bill you know so um these are
good things to know
as the guidelines which is why i
mentioned so many of them so you can see
okay this is what all the experts are
saying
take those and work with them how you
want maybe take a little bit from this
pile a little bit from this pile and
tell the stories you want to tell
in the best way you can figure out how
to tell it
you